has National diabetes months comes to an
end Rocky spoke with a doctor from
Center well senior Primary Care the
sponsors of this segment to help spread
awareness
Dr Wakefield welcome back
it's great to be here again Rocky good
to see you again November is National
diabetes month um so how common is
diabetes among our seniors
so as the seventh leading cause of death
diabetes has become something of an
epidemic in the United States around 130
million Americans are living with
diabetes or pre-diabetes and one in four
people over the age of 65 have diabetes
Now the majority of these are type 2
diabetes which is often referred to as
adult onset diet and we know that being
overweight and inactive are key
contributing factors to type 2 diabetes
and what exactly is happening in the
body when they have diabetes or or are
pre-diabetic
so when you have diabetes you have too
much sugar circulating in the
bloodstream over a long period of time
and the body often loses its ability to
regulate glucose this is type 2 diabetes
and it's a chronic health condition and
makes it harder to lead a long healthy
life it can cause serious health
problems and seniors such as heart
disease vision loss kidney disease and
more now how do you treat that
well right now you know there's really
not a cure for diabetes but you can
manage it with medications or insulin
therapy as well as by losing weight
eating well and exercising the great
news here though is that it's largely
preventable but this means not only
focusing on diet and exercise but also
keeping in mind social and emotional
health it's important to recognize
symptoms of depression or anxiety that
actually may prevent a person from
following a care plan
that's great advice now how can someone
tell if they're diabetic or becoming
diabetic some warning signs I guess well
I guess interesting it's like about a
hundred million adults in the U.S have
PRI pre-diabetes actually and close to
90 percent don't know it there often are
no symptoms so it's important if you're
concerned to really reach out to your
doctor for some simple testing and then
you can find out if you're at risk as
being pre-diabetic and then you can
avoid you know developing type 2
diabetes through Lifestyle Changes such
as eating well maintaining a healthy
body weight and exercising now does
Center well specialize in treating
diabetes
well absolutely we offer team-based care
for a range of chronic conditions
including all types of diabetes this
includes routine exams and testing
medication Management Mental and social
health services and more and we provide
seniors with preventative care programs
help to design to keep them healthy and
active and avoid developing diabetes
altogether if you have any questions or
want to learn more visit centerwell
lasvegas.com or call the number on your
screen to request a tour of the nearest
Center well senior Primary Care Center
our care teams are here to answer any of
your health related questions
our thanks to Center well senior primary
care for sponsoring this segment they
have 11 locations across the Las Vegas
Valley if you'd like more information
just to head to
centerwelllasvegas.com Las Vegas now
we'll be right back